happy monkey pox monday everyone i
i hope you had a glorious weekend i did
i was in salt lake city utah fantastic
people here's me and a few of my friends
having a typical saturday night out
[Music]
i look like jason chavets
they do
speaking of lazy
lazy river
besides uh
president biden's numbers are looking up
as in looking up from a bottomless pit
in hell
say hello to ted kennedy
according to a cbs news ugov poll most
americans believe things are going badly
under distracted and incontinent i mean
incompetent
biden nearly eight in ten voters say uh
things in our country are going somewhat
or very badly now for a comparison
getting your face eaten by a chimp
gets better reviews
science
speaking of chimps we got a new concern
it's called monkey pox
and it's not as fun as it sounds
kind of gross actually and according to
the world health organization this
disease is being spread by sex at raves
in europe
so just to be safe no raves for me
in europe
definitely no sex with monkeys at least
for two weeks
you gotta flatten that curve
and it is it is shaped like a banana
get it out of my system we're gonna be
covering a lot of monkey pox and as far
as we know it's not spreading here i
think
oh this whole monkey pox virus is
completely overblown
everyone here at the labs infected and
we're perfectly fine
yes no applause all right
back to the poll
so nearly 70 think the economy is fairly
or very bad and 56 disapprove of how
biden's doing his job
and if the election were held today he'd
be in bed at noon
all right fair enough you didn't laugh
it's okay
but that's an hour earlier than normal
here's an interesting fact 65
say that when important things come up
biden is slow to act well unless it's a
stock tip from hunter but close to close
to 40 percent of dems feel the same way
we asked president biden if he thought
he was slow to act and he replied
thursday
which was an answer to a question from
two weeks ago
bull did fine 35 believe biden addresses
problems right away
where do they find those people
[Music]
never gets old when asked to describe
their feelings about the state of the
country most people use phrases like
uneasy or worrying and also frustrating
which is how kamala harris describes
reading
but oddly 11 percent said the state of
the country was calm and another seven
percent said inspiring
inspiring are you
again who are these people
[Music]
so there's something deceptive going on
here yeah biden's slow to act especially
when you look at the major crises like
inflation crime the border baby formula
pete davidson embarking on a film career
joe's like the guy who says he's going
to help you move apartments but shows up
after the work is done just to eat the
free pizza
although in binds america nobody would
end up getting pizza because the
delivery driver would be carjacked and
shot on the way
but joe wears joe's nowhere to be seen
except when it's too late
i wonder what joe's got to say
no no no no look look you
you don't think i've done this before
come on man it's you want to talk tough
with joe
this is not
my first rodeo all right
i've been on this dance floor before you
dance with the one who brought you right
you put your right foot in you put your
left foot in
you put your right foot in you shake it
all about
you do the hokey pokey come on man that
that's what it's all about
get out of my face
so
thanks
we ask that you save the applause until
after all the awards are given
but being slow to act is that the case
all the time seems to me joe actually
acts fast when it serves his woke agenda
remember the executive actions he
unleashed the moment he took office if
you bought gas or insulin recently you
do but that was the point his election
wasn't about doing something but undoing
something erasing the previous four
years as quickly as possible his
presidency has been like an episode of
flip this house
the demoing of the kitchen is way easier
than the building of the new one only in
joe's case he didn't replace the kitchen
with anything at all well except for the
corn pop story and he showed him right
there are other places where he acted
with lightning speed remember accusing
the border patrol agent of whip and
haitian migrants he didn't even wait for
the facts before he smeared him remember
written a house i bet joe doesn't but he
called him a white supremacist turns out
the only thing joe should be president
of is
cnn about any opportunity where he could
divide the public any time he could
blame half the country or label them
racist he acts faster than a hit a crack
or meth depending on what hunter's got
with him
so when we say that biden is a slow
walking disaster we only wish that was
the case he actually does bad things
super fast one minute he's a yawn the
next he's flesh eating bacteria i mean
he was able to destroy a country that
was doing just fine when he took over in
just months he replaced not getting us
into endless wars with the brink of
world war iii domestically he's a double
barrel disaster sure he's an empty
vessel but the emptiness has been filled
by an opportunistic infection called
wokism he's like a newborn child adopted
by the manson family
he isn't merely a president he's a host
a host to a parasitic disease that
infected his party and our institutions
so we got to localize this infection and
forget monkey pox we got a pox in dc and
joe's the monkey
if he invites you to a rave
don't go
let's welcome
tonight's yes
she's so sharp you might poke your eye
out just by looking at her former senior
counselor to the president president
trump and author of the new book here's
the deal killian conway
he's even smarter than his accent makes
him sound foxy's contributor douglas
murray
he's so texan mechanical bulls trying to
ride him at bachelorette parties
go host at fox in france weekend will
cave
and finally in for cat tip she's so
southern she sweats moonshine fox
business anchor degan mcdowell
kellyanne congratulations on this big
thick book it's a door stopper it is a
door stopper and a heart stopper just
like your outfit today holy crap
you're like a shiny penny if it was
worth something
by the way i checked the index and i'm
not in the book but that's okay you're
in the family picture surprised yes i
know how did i get into that do you
think uh when you look at what's going
on right now do you think that it would
have had this decline would have
happened so quickly
no no and less time that it takes to
have a baby they ruined the country yes
and that often ruins countries babies
but
but
look joe biden i mean how low can you go
joe is really the theory of the polling
case for his presidency and there are
many ways to look at these polls
and come up with the conclusion that
america is actually looking past him now
right because he hasn't done course
correction independents have left him
suburban women are upset many of the
biden 2020 voters are now skeptical they
won't even admit to pollsters that they
voted for them right and he's only a
degree higher really than his vice
president so the two of them i'm not
disappointed that the democratic party
for all of its claims of being about
youth and energy and
freedom and the future is being run by
an old angry white man is that funny
that's the irony of the whole thing and
you make a great point and douglas i
want to because you you being british
yes there's always like an anti-british
thing when i was just going to say
finally you're here in a real country
okay
[Applause]
our furniture is like human size
you know
where did you go in britain
i lived inside a tree
i was a little i was a keebler elf
isn't it a testament to the us in a way
that we can endure incompetent
leadership it's like almost like the at
the best analogy i was thinking of this
the other day is like the founders
created a self-driving car
and so whoever's in the front seat
generally can't destroy it except joe
invited a bunch of children you know
into the into the driver's seat and
that's what we're kind of dealing with
the analogy almost works see typically
um i i look like the ones i want to
speak to are those seven percent who say
that they're inspired yes
seriously where did you get those people
i think you watch gut fellas
seven percent of them who feel like this
is all just like oh god i can't wait for
tomorrow this is
so great i just can't wait for the next
announcement and the next roll back of
the next announcement is just so good
yes i don't know where these people are
found yeah i don't know either but i
mean i think in every population there
are insane people and they take the
polls yeah well have you ever been
phoned by pollster uh i don't think i've
ever been i don't think i've ever had a
phone call period
generally people don't call me i don't
have very many friends but i've learned
to live with that uh i like to consider
myself a loner a recluse
i collect a lot of things will i would
call tv effect right now just you could
have a phone call on television yeah
i'll have your number do you know do you
think it's funny
it's not on friends and family it just
isn't
isn't it don't you think that the big
problems don't bother joe biden because
he's so old and it's like
how much time do i have left
he doesn't think about us he thinks i'm
going to go home and eat jello
you know i think it can sound flippant
or dismissive but i think kellyanne's
two choice adjectives are absolutely
correct old and angry the american
people can forgive many things i think
they can even forgive some of their
quality of life that they've given up in
terms of inflation and crime they cannot
forgive the kind of incompetence they
see at a podium on a weekly basis and
then when you combine that and it
reminds you of sort of like your 80 year
old grandpa i don't want to eat my
tapioca he's not in control he's not
going to be bossed around all right
those are a lot of our audience will
i love our taffy we love our
grandfathers who eat tapioca pudding
that may be the gut-felt audience but
not on fox and friends oh really yeah um
you know i think his reaction is to be
aggressive and angry then in those
moments when he can show some
independence it is i will not do that
and then he comes across as angry and
that anger is also unappealing when
combined with incompetence it is true it
goes through a dramatic effect and it
just comes off as bizarre you know it's
like it's like road rage you know at the
time it feels really good and then
everybody's staring at you
especially when you don't even have a
car
just on the road
[Laughter]
wandering into traffic
yes yes
you know there were some people in the
media that claimed that joe's doing a
great job by every metric they always
use every metric what do you think
they're taught like what metric would
they be doing
the only metric i can think of is he's
good at
maybe making people feel sorry for him
because like is the only possible
strategy at this point could be
being so pitiful
that he's doing that to get people to
cut him some slack
like oh you leave him alone he thinks
elon musk is his wife's perfume
i can tell you though that that doing
this does not work because i was working
this angle in high school
trying to get boys to suck face with me
just out of pure pity
and it doesn't work it does but i
disagree with you the american people
carry a grudge just like i do i've got a
chainsaw with this guy's name on the
side of it who dumped me when i was in
my 20s what was his name
i'm not telling you
so but i i i have to say this yeah i
worry about what you just said i think
too many people talking about joe
biden's obvious mental deficiencies and
deficits as a president does create
sympathy for him and sympathy makes
people say you know what i think barack
obama is really running the white house
the country the democratic party i feel
better to create sympathy
for joe biden's to excuse him and i
think this man should be made to eat and
own every bad policy he has foisted on
our shoulders in the last plus year plus
otherwise we're excusing his conduct
he's just happy to be there and you look
at the polls he doesn't do anything well
at this point they had covid for a while
he had a strong hand with covid which is
a joke since trump left him with three
vaccines to put in the arm and he's been
facing three variants
but i wouldn't create sympathy for him
by the way i think politiart of politics
is not telling people what they can
already see it's telling them and
reminding them what they can't see and
everybody can see this man is failing
everybody can see
a vice president who tackles at the most
inopportune times can't really speak
well they don't have people don't have
confidence in their competence i would
remind people where they can't see the
the keystone pipeline gone the chaos at
the border the 106 000 overdose deaths
when we had brought them down for the
first time in 30 years the kids being
taught to hate america and each other
not love america and each other and it
goes on and on yeah it see it also just
the the the fact that he said we make
fun of the fact that he's an empty
vessel and we forget what's being placed
inside the vessel which is a lot of this
woke ideology which is ultimately very
destructing okay we got to move on up
next hillary's campaign manager
testifies about her trump slash rush
alive hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else